Can you hear us okay?
We're gonna head over to the area with the snacks that will
be appearing very shortly.
Shortly.
It's the British snacks we're gonna be having.
They're just bringing out the accent more, I think.
All right.
Well, the American snacks bring out the American accent.
Oh, winner, when I eat those Trader Joe's.
Oh.
Someone's the trite.
Someone's the joe.
All right, I'm starting.
We ready.
Yippee!
Oh, you guys.
Oh, it's so nice.
Can you see us?
Yes, you can see us.
Hi, MVP.
Hello.
Yeah, what is the Girl Scout cookies thing?
Someone was like, how about Girl Scout cookies?
What are they?
I got your trip.
You'll see.
Oh!
Wait, you've never had girls.
Oh, yeah.
What?
When would you have Girl Scout cookies?
I don't know what's that.
Oh my god.
Cookies made through child labor.
Yes.
But no, but delicious.
But they're delicious.
Okay.
I will trust that.
And people always shell out tons of money in front of
supermarkets to children yeah so that they can get the
cookies and then they use the money to like do projects or
go places and like help the community yeah yeah oh so it's
like helping everybody and and the cookies are tasty yeah
well maybe we'll find out oh I got I got I don't know it's a
popular flavor but but we'll see oh oh oh oh I think I think
I may know maybe maybe maybe I've gotten rid of some of my
though.
What was your favorite?
I liked the the smiles one the lemon the cat one.
I love anything lemon.
And then there was like the gosh what was it it was like a
not a s'mores one but it like some mimos.
No those are still around.
Hmm those are still around.
I'll have to have to look and see but they've gotten rid of
all my favorite ones.
Oh no.
Time to riot.
Freak them back.
But they're always bringing like fun new flavors in too.
Oh guys.
Yeah yeah.
By the way and you can chat hear us all reasonably well.
We've got a microphone in the middle, but let us know if
anyone's a bit hard to hear and we can adjust.
Let us know if everything's good.
Also, yeah, first MVP of Collab.
Whoa.
Crazy, look.
What is this shade?
It's a friend.
These are the legs and then the arms and then the ears.
Ah.
Oh yeah, okay.
I see it.
Audio is clear.
Awesome, good, good, good, good.
We're using an old microphone I found in the bottom of a box
somewhere, so that's good that it's working.
Ha ha ha.
Yeah.
How you guys been enjoying your time here?
Enjoying?
Yeah.
Enjoying.
I like being with you guys.
That's been the highlight of it.
so far yeah it's been a little cursed otherwise just a
little bit yeah it's been pretty cursed for me yeah yeah no
i really really hope that you feel better suit everybody
yeah no it is it's also allergy season and stuff too i think
all the balsams are coming out and all that so yeah stuffy
noses all around but oh but yeah no i i hope i hope we get
to all see the maybe if we get decorate together that'd be
nice yeah it got pushed up right yeah so maybe maybe
there'll be a chance you said when what was it apparently
the 18th is when they start booming balloon balloon so maybe
maybe maybe yeah but eight packs of Girl Scout cookies Wow
okay I'm a big fan of the Girl Scout cookies in chat here oh
yeah oh yeah of all the same cookie or just like different
kinds of cookies.
All the same.
I mean, I get it.
If you've got a flavor of something that you like, I'm the
kind of person, whether it be food or anything else, like
the dress I'm wearing today, I have the same one in three
colors.
I just rotate the same one.
I get it, though.
I do, yeah.
I'll get new stuff and then I'll be like, but I always go
back to the same clothes.
That's me at like a Coldstone or something.
I've been getting the same thing since I was a kid.
And then you just go try anything else because you're like,
well, this works.
Why would I like my money on something i might not like
exactly make sense make sense do you have to reserve spots
for sacro viewing i feel like that's like very popular
places that people go early and they put the picnic mats
down oh right it's like a freak rules like put my mat down
you're like the disney people that like wait for the parade
oh yeah they just sit there in the way dedication yeah and
then there's some people who like there's only like i don't
know three of them but they put out like the most massive
mat ever just like reserve this huge space there's just like
a few of them in the middle it's like well have you done
this yeah kind of crazy what are you guys interested for us
to try first because we have yeah we have an array of both
american and british snacks so we've got to decide which one
we're going to start with i feel like Both are very
exciting.
Should we alternate or should we separate the sections so
you can, like, be completely immersed in the British taste?
Do you have a lot of British stuff?
Well, by the way, thank you, Steinem Mane, for preparing all
of the British stuff.
Yeah, thank you.
There's quite a lot.
There's, like, there's quite a lot of crisps, cakes, snacks,
biscuits.
Lots of different things.
Although I do think that for some of the British stuff, we
definitely want a nice cup of tea with it.
We definitely want a nice cup of tea.
Yes.
I brought five things.
Five things.
Okay.
I had so much I bought all in a nice Trader Joe's bag as
well.
Wait, wait, wait.
Without even discussing it, Lenten, I both ended up going
and shopping at Trader Joe's.
Yeah.
But like, I got to the airport and my housemate called me
and she was like, Phoebe, you left your entire Trader Joe's
bag.
No, no.
So I wonder if we bought some of the same things.
Maybe.
I only got two things in Trader Joe's.
Other things are.
Did you get any peanut butter cups by any chance?
No.
Okay, because I heard you can't get those over here.
So I was like, I'm going to get peanut butter cups.
I wish I did.
But then I didn't bring them.
I don't like peanut butter, so that's good.
If we're not in your favor, that's good.
I mean, I will try my best if there is peanut butter.
I know that peanut butter is an American staple, so I will
do my best.
Yeah, oh, nice.
Awesome.
I, like, didn't know if I liked it or not for a while,
because I was too, I didn't want to have nuts things.
But then I starved on a plane once, and all they had was the
plain peanuts.
But they still, they still served the peanuts back then.
And then I made myself eat it, and I was like, well, this is
good.
It's pretty good.
So now I do like peanut butter.
I love nuts.
But do you like the chunky peanut butter or the smooth
peanut butter?
Both.
It depends.
But I hate Japanese peanut butter.
Oh, I've never had it, is it different?
It's Japanese peanut butter.
It's like a gel.
It's so...
It's so bad.
It's more like a paste, right?
At least when I've had it in like chocolate.
Peanut paste.
Like Reese's Pieces and all that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
Now, gel sounds a little bit vile.
This is going to be me after the snacks.
I think my face is covering him.
Oh, can you see him?
Oh, yeah.
This is gonna be me.
He just came in the mail the other day.
The fat Usagi, look at him.
Fat Usagi.
So cute.
That will be me.
Sorry, I have a lot of sugary snacks.
I'm excited.
Don't apologize.
Do not apologize for sugar.
Sugar.
It's what time?
11 a.m.
time oh sorry snack time snack time perfect time between
breakfast and lunch when nothing's going on it's time to
snack snack o'clock baby snack o'clock all right shall we go
for something a little bit weird to start with oh we're
going in we're going guys all right well maybe i should go
for the ones that i think wait i hope i hope steiner got
them they'll be in here ah steiner where are the Wait, hang
on.
Oh, and the who's it?
Oh, no, I don't know.
And the what's it?
And the thing of a ball.
Yeah.
But we'll have to try some of these.
Okay, right, I'm gonna get out some of the slightly weird
ones to try first, I think.
Okay.
So.
A British staple.
Let me set the scene.
Okay.
You're a kid in the UK.
You've got your sandwich.
Ain't no, ain't no cute bento boxes.
You got your sandwich and you got your monster munch pickled
onion.
Monster munch pickled onion.
Is this like a funnion?
Oh, maybe.
What's a funnion?
It's like a, what is a, what's a funnion?
It's like a onion ring kind of thing, but it's not an actual
onion.
Oh, yeah, yeah, maybe, maybe it tastes a bit like that.
These are pretty strong flavored.
Okay.
But you guys can see if you like them.
Oh, I should get wipes on.
you guys can like cleanse your hands off but let's let's
open them and find out i want to smell yeah smell the bag
smell the bag it smells like pickles whoa it just smells
like a real pickle huh yeah it smells like the mcdonald's
pickles give it a go guys give that what's the much pickle
onion should we rate everything out of 10.
they don't look like are you shaped funny yeah they don't
look like the bag at all like uh this thing oh they do they
do yeah they're shaped like little monster feet they're more
orangey on the back yeah wait oh their feet yes feet oh i
thought they were teeth they're so thick yeah if we
interlocked toes like oh they were thick so they are thick
you just eat the whole thing in one bite yeah yeah just go
for it it's so thick just go for it
Oh, you like, you like, you like a Monster Munch Pickled
Onion.
It's actually so good.
Yeah, right.
It's like quite a, it's a very distinct flavour, but this is
a British staple, guys.
If you like a Monster Munch Pickled Onion, if you want, you
can probably have UK citizenship.
It's...
Oh, so I'm...
We're British.
British.
It's funny because it has a strong taste and a light taste
at the same time.
Like, there's something light about it.
Yeah, right.
Can I have one just because I want one?
I mean, I know what these tastes like, but I'm going to have
one anyway.
Hachi, you like it, Vicky?
I know it's so good, huh?
Mm.
I'm going in second for, well, we can't eat too much, I
guess, because there's so many.
Yeah, we can always, like, save it for, like, more snack
parties later.
Yeah.
Oh.
gonna be like let's just eat it all this is all good but yes
let's set this aside all right next slightly weird one okay
twiglets okay so twiglets are twigs I like that twigs twig
they are twigs in a bag twigs in a bag yes twigs in a bag um
they they taste uh i think they're marmite what's marmite oh
no it's a marmite oh i've had vegamite vegamite vegamite is
very similar but yeah it's got that kind of like marmite
marmite flavor as a brit i apologize for these i'm sorry no
these are a british staple and they will love them what do
you mean you're sorry for these absolutely not right okay if
nikki's All right, guys, Lincoln logs, right?
Imagine you're in the forest.
Lincoln logs, Lincoln logs, Lincoln logs.
What is Lincoln log?
When we were talking in the podcast about like childhood
toys.
Oh, those things.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You told me about those.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I would suck on the Lincoln logs as a kid.
So does it taste like wood you can relive that experience
imagine you're in the woods.
Oh They really look like sticks in the woods.
You got nothing else to eat and you see some some twigs on
the floor now go for it Try one so for it's very poor But
I'm kind of scared it looks just like a twig It does doesn't
it?
Yeah, look at that.
Oh some of them are Nasty looking than others.
They've been in the mud like Is this cinnamon?
What is this?
Marmite.
Oh yeah.
Whoa.
It's kind of bitter.
Oh yes.
You know what I would expect a stick to taste like.
You know what it tastes like what I would expect a stick to
taste like.
So actually it's completely accurate advertising.
I should have saved my tea.
Oh, I have water.
Seems like excellent reviews all round, I think.
And I need my water.
I'm going to read it in the back real quick.
Crunchy, savory, whole wheat sticks.
Savory huh?
Savory.
Wow.
What a unique experience.
Entertain your senses.
no way oh my gosh only twiglets give you that distinctive
nobly shape nobly shape combined with a zingy taste and
crunchy bite for all round sensual satisfaction sensual oh
damn twiglets everybody in twiglets okay monster munch what
did you guys vote the first one well we need to give our
ratings oh out of 10 yeah there was a 10 out of 10.
yeah yeah 10.
okay a slightly different scale then how about the
twiglets um the britain the britain it's got an accurate
twig shape which is fun i find myself winning seconds oh
really yeah yeah yeah that's a thrill there maybe maybe i'm
gonna go in it's high in fiber i think i am essentialized
you know i will try one more maybe maybe i'll be able to
accurately see how i feel that i don't just um five five out
of ten five i saw five i mean that's more than i thought you
were gonna get really that's not terrible but I like I would
not eat this willingly yeah okay it's not terrible but you
would not eat it willingly they could definitely put that on
the packaging I think all right maybe it's time for some
American American snake all right I'm ready I'm ready to eat
my American snakes check I'm Victoria Roman and I'm ready my
friend was like you have to get these I'm I've never heard
of them before.
I have heard they're good, but I haven't found them myself.
I knew it, I knew it.
Yeah, and then.
Oh, this is childhood.
Yeah, and there's three different things too, so I was like,
this is, oh shoot, that's good.
And then this is what I got from Trader Joe's.
Oh!
I think I just wanted corn.
Which is that?
And then these I got from Trader Joe.
I just wanted corn.
Let's go through this one.
You feel like a gushers.
Yes.
Here we go.
Oh
wait, where is it?
Gushers!
A little chibi, how would he describe?
They're like, if you have ever like seen cartoon jewels in
like, and like you've been like, wow that looks delicious, I
want to eat that.
Or like a kale shim roll?
Yes, yes, yes!
Yeah, but imagine that like, you bite in the Chaos Emerald,
and then all of its power explodes in your mouth.
It's like that.
That's why it comes to you now.
Yeah, you can say that when you eat it.
I'm so excited.
I'm gonna say Chaos Control as I eat this.
What flavor are they?
What's a different flavor?
What's a different fruit?
It's a fruit flavored snack.
Fruit flavored snack.
Fruit flavor.
I haven't had these in so long either though.
Fruit, I'm like, I don't even remember how they taste.
I kind of wasn't allowed to have them as a kid.
Me too, me too.
Yeah, you too.
Yeah.
But then like, when like friends at school would have them
in their lunches, then I sneak some of them.
Whoa, they're all red.
Look at all of them.
They're all red.
Why?
Oh, I was just looking at the back saying, children should
be seated and supervised while eating.
Dude.
What's gonna happen?
You must be seated and supervised for your gushes.
We're seated for gushes.
Gushes.
Mine are also all red.
What?
It's not just the color they are now.
I think we got a dupe.
We did.
All right.
Okay, so a jewel with lots.
Oh, it looks so nice.
Little rubies.
I know that.
I'm going to taste it.
Do it.
Mmm.
Those are much gushing.
You gotta gush it.
You gotta you gotta buy it.
Yeah, but there wasn't much actual liquid inside.
Oh, there wasn't.
Oh, okay, maybe I'll try another one.
Keep going.
Oh, a little bit more in that one.
Oh, yeah.
I guess it depends.
Some gush more than others.
I'm sorry.
Mmm, but the gush.
Does it taste like America?
America.
It tastes like America.
It tastes like the land of the free the gusher the gushing
are we are we doing honest reviews yeah yeah the strawberry
flavor is a little bit like fake strawberry flavor oh oh
america yeah and i feel like it could have done with more
gushing action i feel like one more okay i'll try one maybe
you got a backpack because i feel like yeah
was there more i'm having another one yeah i think june
fireman summed it up for me limited gosh four out of ten i'm
sorry oh mine didn't go shy though yeah yeah four out of two
wait actually where would you rate the twinkies well twinkly
twinkies wait what are they called twinkies Twiglet.
Most of the much, I would agree.
Ten out of ten.
Twiglets, I mean, as much as I was hyping them up, like, I
wouldn't choose to buy Twiglets.
But they do taste exciting.
So for that, I'll give them a six out of ten.
Oh, and for the gushes, I'm sorry.
They were nice.
Like, I would eat them, but I...
I mean, maybe four out of ten is a bit harsh, then.
No, no.
Five out of ten.
Do whatever you feel like.
Okay, I'm going to go four out of ten.
But I believe that they'll do.
other stuff that will surprise me i will say wait actually
before you give your final thoughts yes mr gusher is my
uncle wait like legit oh yeah so would you please would you
like to uh yes i would i would very much uh like to uh
retract my statement i'm so sorry um gusher
I'm so sorry.
Yeah, this is very...
My uncle works in Nintendo vibes.
My uncle is Mr. Gusha.
Okay, I'm so sorry, Mr. Gusha.
I'm so sorry for insulting your family.
And I would like to...
I would like to reconsider and go for a solid 7 out of 10,
Mr. Gusha.
Yeah, yeah.
I will.
I'll appeal to...
To Uncle Gusha.
I think all of these are the same strawberry flavor.
Oh.
Uh oh.
Well, you're gonna get really used to the artificial
strawberry American flavor.
The flavor of our country.
America.
This one's fun though.
This one's fun.
Or should I?
Is it the...
We used to have these in the UK too.
Oh really?
But for the food.
For the food.
Not the same, but the things are rolled.
Yeah.
What were they called?
I, um, oh.
Not foot, it was called something that wasn't foot.
Well, as a kid I was like, why is it, why is it feet?
But then actually, now I, like, when I think about it, it's
like one foot, right?
Freedom units.
Not like feet, feet.
It always felt longer to me as a kid.
That's so exciting.
Shall we unravel it and see if it's a foot?
Oh, this is so exciting.
That's so, um, is that person's finger like okay?
What?
Oh my god!
I don't know if you, I don't know if chat can see this, this
finger.
Look for flavor here.
Wait, what do you mean?
What does that mean?
Accurate depiction of Lord Finger, guys.
Oh, by the way, Chaz, DVR, mental, no, sorry, I probably
forgot, sorry, I'm, I'm managing a lot of things right now,
Chaz, give me a second.
Um, Choto, a minute.
Let me turn that off for you guys.
Oh, um, I can't.
We can't see it.
Can't see it.
Sorry.
Yeah, we can't, we can't see.
It literally won't load it in.
I guess it's the UBR for you guys.
Have fun.
Um, okay, here we go.
Maybe it was by the meter for you guys.
Does this look familiar?
Shall we extend it?
It looks like a tongue.
I used to do that at the right make it my tongue it's like a
yokai yokai tongue yeah see it looks way longer that's
longer than a foot it's longer than a foot how are we gonna
do this I could like feed it to feed it I also wasn't
allowed to have much of this as a kid either so this is fine
I just eat it I need to keep going I need to keep rolling
yeah okay we're gonna keep I'm trying to keep up.
I'm trying to keep up.
You okay?
Oh, hold on.
The gushers.
Oh, it's just the gushers.
Yeah, it's just the gushers.
Yeah, it's fine.
This is so long.
Whoa.
This is way longer than a foot.
That's way longer than a foot.
Whoa.
Oh.
I don't know why I just did.
That's fine.
Okay, I think that's, I think that's how it is.
I don't think it's going to unfold from there.
Yeah, I don't think so.
Yo.
Bless you.
Thank you.
Oh no, a gush it fell on the floor.
Three second rule, three second rule.
It's okay, you can throw it away.
Okay.
So it's like, hold on, it's like a flip.
Are we actually doing Lady in the Tram?
We'll have to be kind of careful, but...
Yes.
She tries to split here so that you can...
Oh, so hard.
And they go from there to there.
And they go there to there.
Yeah, how would we do three-way Lady of the Trout?
I'm not sure how that would work.
Basically, we'll split it, we'll split it like this.
Oh, we'll split it like this.
And then...
Yeah.
Yay.
See to me, this tastes way better than the gushes.
I think so too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I really like the flavor.
There's something like, and I said it's so, oh, sorry.
So thin too.
Yeah, this is a, if it was thicker, I feel like it wouldn't
be as satisfying.
This is good stuff.
Oh, that's so nice.
No, it's a solid, for me, that's a solid eight.
Whoa.
Solid eight for the foot.
And it's called foot.
That is called foot.
For VTuber fans, I'm sure you understand that that is a real
point for this item.
Big appeal.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, so good.
Foot out of the head.
Yeah, really nice, really nice.
Love that one.
Shall we go back to the British snacks?
Oh, yes, now, this is a classic UK flavor crisp.
And these ones are particularly good, actually.
Yeah, more crisps.
This one's particularly good.
Have you had prawn cocktail flavour?
No.
I've had shrimp chips, but I don't know about prawn
cocktail.
Prawn cocktail.
So there's like a lot of different crisps in the UK that are
prawn cocktail flavour.
So again, UK staple.
Let's hope you like it.
What are these?
Or risk offending the skips.
Skips.
Light and melting.
These are really good because they like, yeah, they like,
they like dissolve in your mouth almost.
They're real.
Really good.
I think you guys, I think you'll like this one.
What if we end up having to change our rating for the
monster, the monster munch after this?
Oh, because the skips are too good.
Yeah.
Yeah, skips, skips are so good.
Go for it, go for it, go for a skip.
Is this just a shrimp chip?
Hold on, I'm gonna have it.
That is shrimp chip texture.
the flavor the flavor it has the cocktail a little bit more
oh skips are so good skip skip mmm that's yummy oh well
let's do your crisps well I will admit they taste less
flavorful than they did when I was a kid oh maybe they took
some of the dodgy flavorings out but we want the dodgy
flavor yeah maybe but no I think those are pretty good those
are pretty good all right what do you what do you reckon
what do you reckon for the skips between between these guys
which one did you like better this one right it's like a
little more flavor yeah i love the texture of these yeah
right but also i think i just like my dad's favorite is
shrimp chips so i had a lot of them and i'm like this is
that but like a little less flavorful yeah but they used to
be more like coated in the powder.
It's hard times.
Hard times, yeah.
They lower in all the...
Shrimp power.
All those... or whatever, E numbers or whatever was the
number.
Yeah.
In which case, I think this is like a good... is it a...
eight or...
Yeah, I was gonna say a seven or eight for me.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, seven or eight.
Yeah, six or seven.
Yeah.
They're very easy to eat, though.
No!
Can I just go?
I'm like, I'm holding back so bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Anyway, let's move on.
Let's move on.
Okay, I'm just gonna try not to spill the twiglets.
Um, okay.
And then Steiner said he needed this bag, bag that they're
all in.
So we'll auction that off to you guys afterwards.
Let us know.
Yeah!
Let us know how much you want.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, let's go for this.
Oh, yes, oh, yes.
Oh, yes.
Arrow, you guys have had Arrow.
Oh!
I've seen this guy.
I've seen them before, I've never had them, though.
And it's specifically mint flavored.
Yeah, mint flavored.
The peppermint arrow.
Okay, so what's so good about Arrow?
It's just so like, it like melts in your mouth.
I mean, the chocolate literally like tastes like this.
It's like little bubbles.
It's really good.
All right, let's get these out for you guys.
Did you get peppermint flavor for like specifically because
that's the best one?
I mean, personally, I would have gone for the regular, but
Stein aboard these.
Oh, right, right, right, right.
But.
Wait, can we just eat the whole thing?
Yeah, we could.
It looks like you can break it apart.
Oh, or you can break it apart.
I mean, if you wanna do that, you can break one apart if you
wanna, I mean, there's lots of snacks still to come, so.
Yes.
Are you guys the kind of person that like separates your
chocolates that have like, you know, these markings, or do
you just like bite into it like a heathen?
There's no judgment either way.
I think I bite into it like a heathen.
Oh, it smells good.
It does smell good.
Oh, it came out.
It's very pretty.
Yeah, look guys.
Wow.
Look at that.
It is literally like the colors of, colors of your outfit,
Mindos.
Okay, it's time.
You like it?
I really like it.
Big, big, big ups from Phoebe over here.
You can't, you know, you can't go above 10 out of 10.
If it's something that you really feel deserves it, you can
go to like a 15, you know.
Really?
Yeah.
Well, that's good to know.
It just melts.
I love that texture still.
Yeah, it's like a bubble bath.
I don't know why I should.
It just makes me envision a bubble bath in my brain.
No, these are good.
I never thought I would like the flavor because I was so
confused about it.
Mmm.
That's really good.
That's tasty.
Never mind.
Maybe I do like these better than the original era.
That's so good.
Wait, I want to have the whole thing.
This is like nice and cool and refreshing.
It is.
Yeah.
of it's a pretty tune I'm just gonna eat this this whole
thing well I think we should I think we should compare
peppermints I know I'm gonna go next peppermints I brought
the Girl Scout thin mint crisp chocolatey cookies made with
natural oil of peppermint now huh now wait they go in rowing
I used to do rowing in school so this is like probably one
of the most popular would you say the most popular girl
they're like camoas which are like a coconut chocolate one
yeah okay okay but yeah you got your like little girl scout
they're like we're we're entrepreneurs and we teach you how
of.
We're women in STEM.
Yeah, we're women in STEM.
Oh, yeah, literally says STEM.
Oh, they're so STEM.
Girls in STEM.
Let's go.
What?
Science?
Science, technology, engineering math.
Oh, is that what it is?
We've had this conversation.
before.
I always forget.
I too.
No the E stands for E.
No.
This was my little vest.
I was a brownie.
Oh, cute.
So there's brownies.
What are the rest of them?
Juniors.
I don't know anything else.
Wait, what does it mean though?
It's like your year your rank oh yeah and then you have to
get the number of badges to a badge oh so in the UK for some
reason like the Scout equivalent for girls was called guides
it wasn't called Girl Scouts yeah so I went to brownies and
then guides got bored of guides and then went to Scouts
which was could be like it could be male and female together
oh yeah oh so I went to Scouts I wanted to do like camp and
stuff yeah yeah that's so cool It really depends on like
where you live.
I think probably for your Girl Scout just yeah, yeah But go
ahead and try the tin mint Okay These are made these are
made by the Girl Scouts.
So any if I insult this I'm insulting all of the Girl Scouts
of America Yeah, I don't like it.
Okay.
Every little girl with hopes and dreams are in that cookie
So I will say that Okay, opinions are mixed about this.
But you can see Vicky's face.
No, you don't have to force yourself.
You don't have to force yourself.
Kind of tastes like I've stuck my face in a bonfire.
What?
It's kind of what it tastes like to me.
It tastes very smoky.
Why does it taste smoky?
Does it?
Okay, so I kind of always avoid eating thin mints myself.
I have the other ones.
I like thin mints.
This might be also my first impression.
I always put them in the freezer.
Oh, I heard that's good.
It's like putting pop-tarts in the freezer.
Hold on, let me try this.
Hmm.
Good.
Well, the texture's quite nice.
Yummy!
I think I understand what you mean by sticking your face in
the bottom.
five you know what i mean like when that was my first the
first thing that hit my tongue i feel bad because when i say
that i imagine little minto in a brownie outfit i feel like
i'm insulting little minto you know if i say that these on a
10 out of 10.
well don't give me that face minto minto's doing like the
the pussy boots from shrek but i said as a baker the texture
is really nice oh really nice yeah The flavor I think is an
acquired taste.
And maybe we're just too baby to understand the depth of
this flavor profile.
It's so complex.
I like sticking my face in the bonfire.
I think maybe it's after having the delicious arrow mint, it
also kind of like, comparatively, I'm sorry.
Wait, I'm gonna try combining the arrow mint with the...
This is like cultural exchange right now, all right?
So we stick it like this.
And just put it on top.
And then we just eat it like...
That's like so much in the mid-top.
Whoa!
You could sandwich the min-era in between.
Wait, Phoebe, have you discovered...
Oh my God, Phoebe's look like she's ascending.
She literally looks like she's ascending right now.
The texture of this with the flavor of this, it doesn't
taste like bonfire anymore.
It's just too hot.
It's like...
Whoa, the tech.
on the tech down new tech discovered guys you found it here
the it's girl scouts thin mint with a arrow arrow mint block
sandwiched in between it's the way to go apparently oh i
mean i've always wanted to try a girl scout cookie so i'm
very grateful i gotta i gotta bring you other ones next time
i'm very grateful to little little minto they're very
expensive that's the thing I'm not very, but like $8 for a
box.
Yeah, it's like $8 for a box.
$8?
Yeah.
I mean, I guess you're contributing to their
entrepreneurship and stuff like that, so that's nice.
They should be like free Girl Scout cookies, only $8, you
know?
Only free.
It's like free Supas, you know, but like free Girl Scout
cookies.
Yeah, don't think of it as buying the cookie.
Think of it as buying donations.
Yeah.
And when you think about it that way, I have to give it a 10
out of 10.
no don't don't lie do not lie i mean an accurate rating for
the mission for the cookie itself i'm sorry it's a five out
of ten oh sorry to all the girl scouts of america i'm sorry
they're not gonna let me into america now are they it's not
very controversial your opinion it's not controversial no
even among like it's like 50 50 success rate okay okay okay
that's good there are better there are other ones there are
other ones i'm not gonna say better because it depends on
your opinion however did you notice the trend how we've been
rating american snacks and how we've been rating british
snacks are you saying i'm being negative no no i'm saying
i'm saying vicky's being a spoilsful so far these these
crisps have been rating pretty freaking high yeah but like
these guys for some reason i'm all it's all what that means
chat you know what that means the british are winning who
said the british don't have i might be having skips to get
rid of the flavors nothing nothing oh to get rid of the
flavor that's a good idea no that's not what i'm not gonna
have a monster yeah there's only a couple left thank you
what oh we've got we still got the sweet okay yeah i figured
we should like do all of the the crisp and then do all of
the sweet snacks from british stuff that's the thing though
we've been doing a lot of like sweet american snacks so far
that's why we gonna do that oh don't worry no i do like
those guys yeah i do have other ones all right guys we've
got two more monster munch so you had the original so the
pickled onion is like the og that's like the you know it's
been a bit around you know for it forever right but we've
got some other some other boys to try We've got sweet and
spicy flame.
I've never had these two by the way.
I've never had them.
So it's new for me, too Sweet and spicy flaming hot monster.
I always skip it though.
And Roast beef monster munch.
Roast I'm so excited!
Roast beef monster munch.
Oh, if you don't want to try this, but I mean, you can just
skip the spicy if you want.
Roast beef monster munch.
I also don't eat flaming hot cheetos and stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't do it.
Alright, roast beef monster munch.
I've never had these, so it's gonna be as much of a surprise
for me as it is for you guys.
So, um, I like the beef ones.
Okay, okay, Chad seemed to like the beef ones.
Ooh.
Okay.
Ghost beef?
How are there so many people that have tried these before?
Are you all British?
Everybody here is British.
If they're British, it's like very, very late at night.
I'm going in.
Go for it.
Oh, Steiner has messaged and says, the hot chips in the UK
are nowhere near hot in the US.
They'll be safe to eat.
Oh, okay.
So we could potentially try.
Maybe.
How do you like the little beef?
Whoa.
Oh, dear.
Oh, no.
I can't tell if this is good or bad reaction.
Good, good?
Wait, wait.
Interesting reaction?
Twiglet kind of reaction?
Twiglet?
reaction it's like a roast beef but the texture is not what
the roast beef should be maybe that's like you know that
like six-course gum that Willy Wonka was making in the movie
where it's supposed to be like oh it tastes like a beef
dinner and then a soup and then yeah yeah maybe that's what
it does remind me of I'm gonna I've never had a beef don't
go for it oh Phoebe Phoebe's a fan it is yummy as sometimes
you'll get like the taste like a roast beef spice I'm not
gonna lie I don't like the smell of it so we'll see what I
think of it oh Vicky's got a very negative looking reaction
see it felt it seems like that right it's strange no No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
All you, Phoebe, all you.
Oh, mine.
I can't believe I'm saying this.
This is going to be my lowest rating of the day.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Lower the swiglets?
No, but of the American sex as well.
This is my lowest rating so far.
I'm giving that a solid two.
Two.
No, bro.
The initial taste is so weird.
There's quite a weird aftertaste.
It tastes like a roast beef to me.
It does, but it's not a roast.
No, no, no, no.
Well, I still like this.
one i still the the original one is still the best give me
give me while i'm to take away the pain how about the
there's a small here you can there's only two little bits oh
thank you yes we love we love this yeah this is our this is
the goat yes oh no there you go i'm gonna go onion if you
need some cool monsters monster-yokai ghost uh fairies to go
on your packaging Yeah, we love Monstera Monster Monster
Much.
The Only Pickled Onion.
Yeah.
Yeah, Only Pickled Onion, please.
Oh, you can sponsor me for this one.
Yeah, you can put Phoebe on the Rose of Beef one if you
want.
Wait, so Chat generally likes the...
You guys like this one?
Generally, you like it?
Maybe some people said they said it was okay.
Surely not.
How?
No, no, no.
We like all of them?
Well, let's try the spicy one then.
Try the spicy one now.
Because Steiner says it's safe, so...
I'll give it a try and let you know how it...
Are you sure?
I'll be brave.
I'll try it too now.
I have some drink.
I'll be okay.
You sure?
Oh, I was going to get you guys some tea before the sweet
section of the UK stuff anyway, because you need to
experience it with a nice...
A nice cup of...
I'll bring you guys a tea.
A true experience.
I have a question.
Did Steiner like buy more of these or just three?
I think that's all he bought.
Oh, I will savour this vast one, honestly.
Gotta like preserve it in a little box.
I'll save it for years.
It's good.
I think they sell these in the States.
Oh no, the arrow mints?
I think they sell the arrow ones.
What I heard from another British friend is that the way
that they make chocolate in the US is like literally
different than anywhere else because apparently when the
settlers came over, they were used to having like just like
sour, like rotten milk with them because you know they're
traveling by the boat for so long so they got used to this
like sour like Hershey's flavor that we're used to oh yeah
yeah you know what I mean by it but then if you have
chocolate anywhere else it tastes quite different than what
we're used to so maybe the arrow would be different is one
word to describe Hershey's but I will not go into that as a
child I should have brought it it's so bad though it is okay
you guys agree that it's bad.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
But then like, as a kid, that was one of the only candies I
was allowed to have was Hershey's chocolate.
So I, I mean, I like, what is it, when you're like attached
to your captor?
What is it?
What's that called again?
Oh, Stockholm.
Stockholm.
I love Stockholm syndrome to Hershey's chocolate.
I get it.
I'm trying the hot.
All right.
Oh, so brave.
Me too.
I'm going in.
I feel like in general, yeah, UK spicy stuff isn't all that
spicy.
Is it still like?
the onion flavor but like spicy mm-hmm it's
all right mid why I would describe that one it has no flavor
yeah yeah it's like it I thought it was the same as the
pickled onion but it's not it's a little it's got a tiny bit
of a spice yeah they sprinkled a little bit of tomatoey
spiciness on the top and that's No, the same one is about
Monster Munch.
Focus on your main seller.
Don't lose the plot.
This is the one, Monster Munch.
It's okay to just be good at one thing.
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with that.
In fact, embrace your talents.
Embrace what you're really good at.
Yeah, I agree.
No, solid.
Oh, my God.
I don't know.
It's not a two for me that I don't know.
There was no flavor.
Yeah.
I'm gonna say it.
I was like, well.
It was crazy that this could be a 10 and the other two were
two.
It's, I don't know.
Like this had flavor at the beginning and then it just
disappeared from me.
Like nothing.
That was like a three or something for me.
No, I like a three.
I think a three.
It ain't worth, it ain't worth guys.
No.
It's all it feels like right here.
Okay, only between these two, wish you guys like them.
That one's less offensive.
So if I had, I would not eat either of them, but if I had
them, to i'd rather eat this one i'll eat too whoa i'm i
feel like a freak oh my gosh roast beef must want a freak
all right guys maybe you can prepare the next uh american
one in the meantime i'm gonna boil the kettle ready for the
british sweets should we not do a sweet then maybe well this
is sweet too yeah guys i don't know what these are i've
never tried them but i thought This sounded very American.
Cause like corn is the staple crop of our, of our cornbread
crisps.
Cornbread crisps.
Sweet and salty cornbreads.
Nice.
Oh no, wait, I do need to show chat this.
Oh, what is this?
I do need to show chat.
What is it?
Okay, I'm going to play the sad music.
Oh, what the hell?
Oh, oh, oh.
This is the last one.
Oh, wait, you didn't see.
Wait, Tanya's doing it again.
Okay.
Oh, no.
This is like the death of a British person.
Don't worry.
I think I do have another box.
Let me find it.
Long live the king.
Queen.
What was it?
Who is it?
Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's my vibe.
That's my vibe right now.
Okay, so you are the Pokemon mug.
Are you guys finally just playing the same mug with Rinse in
the Mouth?
I'm okay with that.
I'm still finishing my...
I'm surprised that you...
Okay!
There was that mug that you had me used every time we got
tea.
What was it?
What was the message on it?
Oh, let me read out for you.
Yeah.
There is, my designated mug at Vicky's house says the best
anguish on it.
It's like...
Where is that mug?
Where is it?
It's like one...
Oh, I know where it is.
Ah.
We left it upstairs when we...
Oh, that's why I'm not using it.
I was like, where's my mug?
It says like, one sip makes laugh, two sip makes happy
memory or something like that.
I don't know about how many of the sips after that.
Oh, there it is.
We're doing a dramatic reading.
Ricky's gonna read it.
Okay.
Maybe like here.
One sip makes laugh.
One more sip makes happy and relaxed moments.
What if it's pee in there?
That's a little bit relaxed.
One sip still makes laughs.
It still applies.
All it takes is two sips, guys.
To make happy and relaxed memory.
I want more fruit, but I would put...
Yeah.
Fruity foot.
Pretty feet.
Ooh.
Oh, thank goodness.
Thank goodness.
Oh, you do have another one.
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, yippee!
She found more tea.
It's okay, guys.
I'm still okay.
I have not fainted.
It's all okay.
She's just a little lightheaded, everybody.
Three Sips is very sensual.
A sensual experience.
You guys impressed about how big these boxes are, by the
way.
Yeah, it is pretty.
How much, how many are in them?
240 tea bags.
240 but can we see 240 tea bags yeah open it yes Yorkshire
tea Yorkshire tea fresh box unboxing here we go now this
this is the kind of content that British people like oh yeah
oh yeah oh look at that it's just all stacked in there it
just be like that I've never had a Yorkshire tea you will
love it all right Alfie are you okay to have one yeah you
know I'll have one this time okay I want to have the
authentic British experience.
Okay.
Minto, do you want a new cup for now?
Um, sure.
Actually, I don't want to waste another cup.
Yeah.
No, it's best for me.
Okay.
Here's this one.
Thank you.
It did the monster munch.
It was a graveyard lunch.
It was a lunch.
It was a monster lunch.
They did the munch.
We did the monster munch.
They did that much.
It was a spooky time crunch.
Oh yeah.
Okay, so I try whatever you guys have picked out for me
while that's boiling.
Yeah.
To be honest, we haven't had this before either, but it
sounded very American.
Cornbread Chris.
Sweet and solid cornbread snack.
Yep.
Keith, you might as well finish off those roast beefs.
Enjoy the flavor of freshly baked cornbread wherever you
are, without turning on the oven.
Made with a fragrant cornmeal and a touch of sea salt, these
slightly sweet Take Anywhere snacks are baked to a golden
crisp.
Crumble them into soup or salad for added crunch, serve
alongside warm chili and cream cheese dip, or simply eat by
the hand.
Oh.
Oh, it's warm chili sounds well.
Chili sounds so good today, it's so cold.
Wait, I can't open it.
I'm so low.
How the heck you're excited to eat these cornbread crates?
This is a relatable struggle.
I am.
Hold on, okay.
Baby, hi.
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to, I'm the same as you.
Yeah.
I know, it's hard.
All right, we need muscle.
Come on, Vicky.
Let's go.
Oh, oh, even Vicky is cool.
Oh my God.
Do we need scissors?
I think so, maybe.
They might come out.
Oh, oh, oh.
Can you hear the air?
Ah!
Yeah!
This is what her training was for.
Oh, yeah.
Damn.
Okay, it's molded.
This is your cornbread Christmas.
You want to smell them?
Oh.
I don't smell anything.
Yeah, it'll smell like anything.
Oh yeah, can I smell?
Yeah, go for it.
Yeah, it really doesn't smell.
Like, it's really hard to put a finger on what it smells
like.
The bag is mostly empty.
Ah, it's America too.
It's all air.
Yeah, welcome to America.
Sweet and solid cornbread snake.
Cornbread.
All right, let's have that true American snake.
Okay, we'll try it too.
Yeah, because we also, I mean so Trader Joe's does really
good at snacks but I will try these these have been really
good with some cheese yeah right right I say oh I taste the
cornbread dude that's like legit cornbread it's even got
like the little residue that cornbread has little Trader
Joe's does not disappoint no those are lovely these are good
right these are really good these are really good what hey
those are my favorites so far of everything well What was
the highest rating I gave?
Quite low, I think.
Those are the best so far.
Trader Joe's, Julie.
That is really nice.
Yeah, I reckon like.
This was the one other thing from Trader Joe's you got,
right?
Honestly, I think that's like a nine or 10 for me.
This is yummier.
Yeah, I can imagine like, yeah, dipped in stuff with cheese,
they'd be like amazing.
Yum.
Little cornbread.
I don't usually like cornbread.
No, this is so good.
Yeah, I think maybe if cornbread were.
We're like this?
Yeah, like chips, I would eat it.
A crisps, sorry.
Crisps.
Crisps, in this house you will call the crisps.
I know, I'm so sorry.
My tape lay apologize.
I'm mental coughing and I'm blowing my nose.
Yeah.
any water huh mean water no I'm okay thank you it comes and
goes it comes and it goes it comes and it goes I'm glad
you've been like feeling feeling better steadily though yeah
yeah slowly but surely yeah Dan Setsu is dying I'm already
dead this is true I'm immortal yeah this is true I don't I
don't know I don't know if I'm capable of dying or not.
I think I think I need a copper Oh, don't worry Alright guys
now let me just before you drink.
Oh, no, actually I will give this to Minto and I'll show you
afterwards so you can drink something Oh, no, no, that's
okay.
We need to we need to assess the color This is the proper
color that you will have your tea Even this is slightly too
light for me because I'm taking it easy, you know, because
we don't want to give it like, you know Too dark, but that
is that is an acceptable color everyone for your education
thank you wait it's so it doesn't get slightly too light for
you yeah for me anyway oh i love just just give me all the
milk and all this cream or sugar whatever you want sugar oh
you don't need i don't need sugar but the milk would be in
the house yeah i don't usually drink my tea with milk oh you
don't at all not really but this is good this is very good
The ocean tea you kind of need milk and it's like quite a...
Strong.
Mmm.
Delicious.
Milk with a splash of tea.
Oh, wait, no.
Tea with a splash of milk.
Yes, a splash is the correct amount, definitely.
Looked like I was bathing in the mug.
I was...
Honey featuring tea.
Oh, thank you.
I'm just having a little dip in there.
A little sip.
Let's see.
Towards you
a little?
Towards you a little.
Just a little bit more.
A little more.
It's where that chip bag is.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, now that we've got a fresh tea to dip, everyone,
we're going in for the holy the holy grail, the the one.
the only hobnobbs now I had to really I had to try very hard
not to eat these before today's stream I I kept dreaming of
the hobnobbs that I knew were in the bag I kept thinking oh
I must not eat the hobnobbs it took a lot of determination
does that say the OD one yeah the OT one the OT one is that
the default flavor the OT one yes yeah this is this is the
classic hobnob the classic hobnob UK naming sense okay you
guys you guys have anything in America called something like
hobnob where's that quiet we have ding-dong yeah ding-dong
oh ding-dongs and hobnobs yeah all right now feel free to
taste first but then be sure to give it a nice a nice dip a
nice dip yeah a nice dip in your sea covered in crumbs Yeah,
don't worry.
Just, you can get crumbs on tables, fine.
Is there any other?
How exciting?
No.
Wait, this looks yummy.
What's the flavor?
Oat?
Just oat-y, oat-y biscuit.
Oh, it's really yummy.
I'm going to try it without the tea first.
Mmm.
These?
You know those nature green bars that are...
That's exactly what this is like.
It is, but it's soft.
It's softer.
Yeah, it's soft.
Mmm.
Hopefully good review and then let me teach you the
technique.
Okay, okay.
Yes, yes.
Okay.
I want to have a nice dip.
About halfway.
Don't dip too much, otherwise the biscuit will start to
break.
Very nice, very nice.
Mmm.
Taking notes.
Good technique.
Mmm.
yeah we're at the british tea ceremony in japan this is a
traditional british welcome to the british tea ceremony
i'm a hobnobber you're a hobnobber i don't know that's a
thing but sure delicious Delicious.
Mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm.
Delicious.
No, you still want like half the biscuit to still be not
soggy, in my humble opinion.
Uh-oh, the Brits are fighting.
Yeah.
You don't want to dip the whole thing in, guys, because then
the whole thing is gonna be, you want you like, like half of
the, you know, half of the softness and half of the
hardness.
That is how I feel.
Oh, whoops, I dipped the whole thing.
Oh, oh, it's okay.
I'll forgive you.
It's like how I forgive you when you say, um, The forbidden
sleepy one.
Oh It's okay when you say it baby guys.
I've got the EP pass, but that's just me.
Yeah All right, let's keep oh you guys gonna like these.
Okay, there's crumbs everywhere.
Yeah, don't worry.
Are those kitt cats?
No, it's a penguin penguin biscuit.
You guys like these?
Penguin.
It's just called penguin.
So they they used to have an advert for these that was like
penguin pick up a penguin yeah yeah yeah and each of them
have jokes on them or they should oh yeah you'll get to have
a stupid joke on your biscuit as well so let's wait on the
biscuit um sorry very good so it's like the question is like
here on the back and then the answer Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like underneath.
Yeah.
I'm gonna read it.
Here you go, Mento.
Why are penguins good racing car drivers?
Why, Mento?
Because they're always in pole position?
Ha ha ha ha ha.
What does it mean?
Wait, which one are penguins in the north or south pole?
One of them.
South.
Yeah, so I guess they're making a pun about south pole what
does it why is that a good race i don't pole pole position
means like top position oh yeah the first joke went really
well guys chase the next one what's a penguin's favorite
film what
frozen oh i know Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Ah, ah, ah.
It's, it could have been happy beat, but...
Why was the penguin popular?
Why?
Because he was an ice guy.
I would, I would say this joke wins it.
Yeah.
Put out.
I mean, we could, I mean, there's nothing.
We don't have to eat all of them, but we could read all the
jokes.
Yeah, let's read the jokes.
Yeah, more jokes guys, more jokes.
Okay, more jokes.
You know what I'm saying in mine?
Yes.
Why can't penguins play football?
Why?
Because there's snowball!
That one was good.
Oh.
This one's the racing car one again.
Oh, don't worry, yeah, just mine were dupes too.
Yeah, there was like three dupes in there, bro.
Oh, what the hell?
Oh, I need this gacha luck.
Bro.
Alright.
These, I...
I mean, I feel like the jokes are the more appealing part.
Like, the biscuits are fine.
Oh no, the best is going great!
Okay.
Uh, be interested to know what you guys think.
Oh, the biscuits are still pretty good.
I mean, like, what even is it?
Chocolate.
Chocolate biscuit?
Just with chocolate?
Yeah.
Ow.
I like it.
No you like it?
No.
The biscuit and the joke.
It's just no.
I mean, to be honest, they're not my favorite either.
I think the jokes are more exciting.
Yeah, I agree.
There are solid like five or for me?
Are they penguin balls?
What about you guys?
This is what they look like everybody.
It's like so chocolatey I'm sorry.
It's almost like too much chocolate I find.
Yeah.
Yeah that's how I think.
I'm the kind of person that gets like vanilla with a bunch
of rainbow sprinkles at the ice cream place all the time.
My favorite, quote unquote favorite Japanese food is
omarice.
Like this kind of this kind of thing is like so basic but
it's omarice is great.
Yeah omarice is great.
And then like when I tell Japanese people that it's my
favorite, they're like, Kalei.
And I'm like, ah!
No, I just, I just like.
I get it.
But like, I think that because this is the kind of thing
that a kid would like a lot.
Oh, maybe, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's probably why I like it.
And the jokes.
I don't know, I feel like the kids wouldn't.
No, I should have brought the Laffy Tapies.
You're so right.
Wait, are Laffy Tapies?
They also have jokes on them.
Yeah.
Which makes more sense because Laffy, you're laughing at the
tapy.
Why do these penguins have jokes?
Yeah, I don't know.
They've always been like that for some reason.
Oh no, they've got facts on as well.
Did you know the fastest recorded penguin swimming speed was
22 miles per hour?
Damn.
Wow, that's fast.
But yeah, I feel like it's just like chocolate on chocolate
for me.
I don't know.
Yeah, me too.
So Phoebe, have fun with the penguin bars and the roast beef
for Mots and Bunch.
Yippee!
All right, should we pivot to some?
Take it, take it, take it.
American snacks.
We got, oh gosh, all this left is sweet.
Um, we'll do this.
This is also from Trader Joe's.
Trader Joe's.
I've also never had this before, but I think I just wanted
corn everything.
It hasn't failed us so far.
True.
But those cornbreads are gonna take some beating.
That was so good.
Dark chocolate covered crunchy corn kernels.
Oh, crunchy corn kernels.
Crunchy corn kernels.
Arnold's okay straight from the farm from Trader Joe's from
Trader Joe's he lives in Colombia he does I thought these
seemed a little more strange so that's why oh so does Trader
Joe's have like a mascot like like Ronald McDonald or is Joe
like no I'm gonna look this up and see these look strange
they're like powdered kind of.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, why are they powdered like that?
Yeah, they smell kind of funky.
They do smell funky.
So Trader Joe's doesn't have a single company-wide mascot.
Instead, each store features a unique hidden stuffed animal
mascot that crew members hide for children to find.
Whoa!
That's so cool.
That's so cute.
So what's your guys' local Trader Joe's mascot?
So make sure you will look for them.
Okay, so looks alone.
It does look a bit like animal poop of some sort, but I'm
going to give it a go.
It smells like it too.
It's like Suki's poop.
Oh, please don't choke.
Oh, please don't.
He's like, bad.
I'm going to eat it.
It tastes like what you would expect, I guess.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's like exactly what is advertised.
It doesn't taste good nor bad.
the flavors I get that they're trying to go for like salty
sweet but the flavors just don't match each other at all it
doesn't feel like they're together it feels like you're
eating things separate from each other the problem I have is
the dog chocolate is really um gross yeah oh yeah it's an
American chocolate yeah really strange tasting like you can
tell it's dog chocolate but it's like really really old yeah
tastes expired yeah this is not expired best before the 2027
i think chat chat um yeah i'm sorry i'm very sorry i'm gonna
what did i rate the is that our lowest munch two these might
be worse am i gonna bring out a one I surely can't, can I?
You can't bring out a wine.
You're allowed to.
That's why the scale's there.
I feel like at some point, Chad's going to say that I'm
doing different scores for the American and British snacks,
though.
No, but then you rated this one so hot.
Listen, these ones, these are the best things we've had so
far.
I might think even better than the Monster Munch.
Like, they're so good.
They're so good.
Yeah.
So I think the thing is, like, what we've noticed is that
the sweet stuff in america is not so good but stuff like
crisps well to be fair i was bringing it yeah i didn't bring
so many i only brought sweet stuff sorry no no follow your
heart vicky okay then i'm giving the one i'm sorry i'm sorry
gotta go to tell the truth yeah it's like i i want to keep
eating it because i want the corn but i don't want that i I
don't want the dark chocolate.
I like if it was just corn snacks.
Because I did the corn bit.
It's like nicely salty and like kind of good.
Well, like what if you like operated on it like a grape and
you just removed it from its like, its chocolate prison.
You know?
Free it from its chocolate prison.
Yeah.
And then it'll just becomes corn.
The corn's good though.
The corn is good.
Because it's like corn nuts, you know.
You could probably soak that.
Mmm.
Get all the chocolate off.
Right, right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know why my first curse thought was like, and then
drink the water that they were soaking in.
Yada!
She just tastes like the chocolate!
Oh, I'm sorry, but I have to give it a...
Okay, God, oh.
I'm gonna apologize, we're all in agreeance, I think.
It is, it is other bangers left.
I don't even know which to go first.
All right, guys, have you ever had?
What?
A cherry bakewell!
That's so cute!
That's so cute.
It's very, very like, oh.
Getting peak, peak right now, guys.
Absolute peak coming in.
It's going a bit out of focus.
Let me try and get it back in focus.
It's been a lot of snacks.
I know.
It's so pretty though.
Yes, Mr. Kipling cherry bake wells.
And now this, now this guys, this is the stuff.
Exceedingly good cakes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Do you guys like kind of, what, I don't know, like
Marzipanny taste though?
Because if you don't, then you might not like them.
I'm okay with Marzipanny taste.
I don't know.
I've never had Marzipan.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
She's flipping them upside down.
Flipping them sideways.
Oh, they're just little, little, littles.
I'm not a big cherry person, but it's so pretty.
I love cherry.
Oh, then I think you'll like it.
Look at that, guys.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, so pretty!
This is so incredibly exciting.
Eat it up.
Oh, nom nom nom nom nom nom nom.
Nation's favorite it has written on here.
We want you to enjoy these cherry bakewells of their very
best.
Oh, if you are not completely satisfied, you can contact the
consumer care team.
So if you guys have any comments, you don't like them.
You can contact them.
All right.
I'm so excited to know you guys.
What did you just eat?
The penguin thing.
Do you want to eat my penguin?
I'll take your penguins.
Thank you.
Look at my donation pile of penguins.
Wow.
Thank you.
But first, the Kiplings.
Cherry Bakewell.
Oh, these are so good, guys.
How do you eat it?
How do you take it out?
You just take it out of its packet.
Grab it.
You don't shove the whole thing in your mouth.
No, no, no, no.
You can bite bit by bit.
Bite bit by bit.
Oh yeah.
I'm gonna shove it.
That is a bunch of penny taste.
Wait, this is Peeam.
Wow.
You guys got the jam yet?
Not yet.
I'm vibing over here guys.
It's so sweet though.
Yeah, it is sweet.
You know you only want like one at a time.
Oh, wow.
Oh, yummy.
It might be Phoebe's highest rating yet from that page.
It's nice to wash it down with some tea.
It is good with the tea.
I don't know.
I think maybe it's a tad too sweet.
That's it.
It is very, very sweet.
With the tea, it's pee.
Yes, Phoebe!
it why you want to get tea with everything yes baby baby's
winning the green card she's just gonna be britain the green
card i'll be grabbing this day's dream free free green card
mmm num num oh man peak absolute team It just takes me like
a billion bites to eat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But it is very sweet.
It is sweet.
It's yummy, I'm just full.
I'm quite full.
So good.
What have we got left?
I've got two more in here.
One of them is the sweetest thing we've had so fast.
Do you wanna get that over and done with?
This thing.
Oh, there's one more in there too.
There is fruit by the foot, but it's, or fruit roll up, but
it's the same as every, it's the same as like the fruit by
the foot.
But these, I think they should have pictures on them though.
I think so, and they can like punch them out.
Yeah, they used to.
The packaging is so cute, what the heck?
Let me see.
It's so pretty.
I'm still working on my, what is this, my cherry thing?
Oh, it doesn't seem, they don't have any pictures anymore.
What does this mean?
In green?
Ingredients derived from a bio-engineered source.
From a wall.
Ingredients derived from bio-engineered source.
Hi, GMOs, GMOs!
Yes, go!
GMOs!
It just looks like, it's just like a wad of...
of candy.
But the point was the pictures.
Yeah.
And then like, it's nice texture on your tongue.
Yeah, I like the texture.
No, yeah, there used to be tattoos that you could like, they
would be put on your tongue.
We gotta like cut out a picture from it.
Oh, that's so cool.
Can I like lay on my face and then eat it like that?
It looks like it's candy ham, I think.
Candy ham.
We have it on toast.
With the cornbread.
Yeah, put a little bit of it.
Wait, how do you do this?
So keep on rolling.
However you feel like it.
Oh wait, huh?
Oh!
There it goes.
Okay.
Right?
I'm trying, I'm trying, chat.
I'm trying.
You know, this really does feel like truly Americans.
And anyone's wondering why I have three of them.
Oh my god.
Hailing it, like actually.
It's like, I'm watching the silence of the lambs.
Elejit could like breathe for a second.
Like breathe it.
Don't try this at home.
Oh my God.
But they sell a three pack, everybody.
So that's why we have all three.
Yippee.
But yeah, don't eat that.
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna save it for later.
You can't eat it.
It's the same flavor three times in a row.
I didn't even realize that they all...
Dunk, dunk!
What's this?
Dunk?
I've never had these before, but my friend was like, if you
are bringing American snack, you must bring Dunkaroos!
Whoa!
Dunkaroos!
Everybody, who has had these?
Because I've never even heard of them before.
I've heard good things, but like, I haven't had them.
Dunkaroos!
Yeah, so this is the last thing that I have to offer you I'm
so excited Dunkaroos, what's your dunk the dunk?
The dunk witch or the dunk and scoop?
Oh, it's like the ways to dunk.
I see that huh now There you go.
I was trying to origami with the fruit I was trying to make
one of those fortune towers I didn't go I tried I see the
vision you see the vision yeah oh my god what is your
dunking style what's my dunk what's your dunk tech dunk the
dunk wit which or the dunk and scoop okay the dunk and scoop
the dunk and sandwich here we go whoa so what What is the
sauce with it?
I don't know.
I've never had this before.
It looks like it's like birthday cake flavor.
Okay, some kind of icing.
Okay, okay, okay.
Right.
Anyone know what the sauce is?
I don't know.
We're just going to go for it.
All right, we're all going to dunk, guys.
We're dunking.
Okay.
Whoa.
Is that a good amount of dunk?
Yeah, it looks like, yeah.
I think that's an appropriate amount of dunk.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, all right.
I think this is just cookie oh oh took a second to process I
reminded you of a pop-tart oh I like pop-tarts I'm a big fan
of pop-tarts but again very very sweet but yeah it's it's
given it's given it's given pop-tart energy so I like I love
this thing.
Right, that does.
And that seems up in your alley.
Thief's gonna lick the whole thing out of that.
It's just like a sugar cookie.
Yeah, no, I like that.
For like, I should have brought loft house cookies.
You know what I mean?
You, Chad, you know what I mean?
Like they're like the sugar cookies that you get at like,
like Safeway or Vons or something.
And then they're just, and then there's like a frosting on
top and then like sprinkles.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, those are also divisive, but to me, they're peak.
Yeah.
Some people are like, they taste like Play-Doh, and I'm
like, well, good Play-Doh.
Play-Doh.
I love the Play-Doh.
Oh, yeah.
I need to know.
Yeah, next time, next time I need to taste the Play-Doh
cookies and find out.
Yeah.
Oh.
No, I'll swallow it eight out of ten.
Okay.
Yeah, I like that.
I like it.
That's tasty.
I think if we hadn't had so many sweets today, it would have
been good.
It would have been tasty.
Oh, and then this and then you're drinking with the tea.
Hold on.
Love.
Are you dumb out of tea?
I'm out of tea.
I'm out of tea!
Oh my God, yeah.
No, that's good.
I like it.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, they taste like sugar, but it's compelling is what
someone said.
Yeah.
Mm.
Minto, you might have biscuit in your hair.
I have biscuit in my hair.
Yeah.
Am I okay?
I'm making it out.
Okay, I found it.
I found it.
It's okay.
You have a good eye.
I'm just like...
So many sweets.
Is that a Capri cream egg mug?
Of course it is.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
I forgot to us.
I started to bring cream.
Cream eggs are peem.
Oh yeah.
Cream eggs are very decisive.
Have you guys had one?
I think I've had them before.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel like a lot of my friends are like, I hate them.
They're too sweet.
Oh, they are very sweet though.
But they're so good.
They are really good.
They are so good.
They're so good.
Yeah.
All right.
I don't know if this was a good idea, but we've got one of
the sweetest things now.
Oh boy.
Now this, this is something specifically I think I asked
Steiner to order because it's not super easily available.
Okay.
So let me explain the law behind this stuff.
Kendall mint cake.
Yeah.
So.
British man.
Yeah, yeah.
So this stuff is like, originally it's kind of, it's like
quite a traditional thing.
It's like for hikers to give them like a sugar boost when
they're like walking the Yorkshire Dales and all that.
Or walking, I think this, it's technically in the lakes.
So like the lake district.
So when they're walking, walking the lakes hiking around to
give them like an energy boost.
And my dad always used to give us this while we were out
like hiking stuff and we'd be like, Oh my God, it's so good.
So.
Is it white chocolate?
No, it's mint.
It's literally just blocks of mint.
What?
Sugar and mint.
But it's so good.
It's so good.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Kendall mint cake.
I don't think it's a protein bar if it's just sugar.
Right?
Or I guess protein bars do have sugar, a lot of sugar in
them.
But, uh, whoa.
Whoa.
Just like, you just got to break some off.
Well, you show it to the class.
This is so interesting looking.
Whoa.
What the heck is that?
It's just like a block of sugary mint, look.
It's so good.
All right, you probably won't want more than this eat, to be
honest with you.
Oh, it smells very...
Oh, it looks so young.
It feels young.
Like in my hand, it feels young.
Yeah, it's cool.
It's cool to the touch.
Cheers.
Why is it so good?
Huh.
Okay, when people say that they're eating...
Not eating peppermint is like eating toothpaste.
This is like eating solid toothpaste.
Maybe that's what I like because I used to eat toothpaste
with kids.
Yeah.
Now this is straight up eating toothpaste.
This is actually eating toothpaste.
Whoa.
It's such an experience.
I like it though.
I almost want it to be more sweet.
even more well like it tastes kind of salty to me a little
bit really yeah interesting so good no i'm not gonna lie
this is this is my fab of the whole day i love this stuff
it's so good
my brain is so confused like it's like yummy and texturally
it like makes me really happy but then the Mint flavor is
so, so, so strong.
I'm brushing my teeth, this is what, I like it.
You like it.
I like it.
I don't know how much I like it, but I like it.
Phoebe, Phoebe, I've been brutal with some of these ratings.
Just go for it.
If it's a two, just say it.
She's gonna, I gotta take a sip.
It's going back and forth in my brain between being like an
eight and being like a three.
I don't know.
Mmm.
10 out of 10 10 out of 10 yeah honestly I might I might just
because it's so unique to you I might go above and go for
like a 12 out of 10 from me I feel like it's such like a
interesting thing what I loved as a kid was his one there
it's a type of peppermint but it's so creamy it like
dissolves in your mouth and that's what this reminds me of
so it's really good yeah there's like there's like a little
white they're like little white balls oh yeah yeah and they
they just the way you when you crunch them they like melt
into it this is this is that are you going for a three or an
eight Phoebe mm-hmm I'm scared mm-hmm well we'll put it out
like a for me I'm putting it out like a seven okay I'll take
I'll take a seven I'll take a seven mm-hmm a mint flavored
candy is what it's described it's just so overwhelmingly
like strong wait guys Romney's killer mint cake was the
first mint cake to be successfully carried to the top of
Mount Everest in 1953 being the first successful expedition
to the summit why would you take this your mouth would be
like you know what we need this for guys we have to do MVP
climb Fuji yeah take this with us Yeah.
They're trying to take the mistake.
Yeah.
I feel like a hamster eating this, like, oh, oh, oh.
It's so, it's got such a nice texture.
I love the texture.
What's it?
Jaffa cake.
I'm just a jaffa cake.
Saving something good for the finale.
Okay, this is the British snack finale, guys.
Is there any more American snacks?
Nope.
This was the finale of the finales.
A jaffa cake.
wasn't there like a debate oh yeah about how to classify
java cakes yes I think so like whether they were a biscuit
or a cake yes that was a long a long yes there was indeed
what was the conclusion do you know I don't know but they're
good they're so good chatty you know is it a biscuit or a
cake but it says cake it does say cake so I think we have I
feel I feel like they feel more like a cake to me they don't
have a crunch i feel like for me biscuits kind of have to
have some kind of war is still going yeah the war why why do
they think why are there some people who say it's a biscuit
why i guess we'll try we'll see it we'll see feby look yeah
we'll classify we'll end this debate yes yes okay let's
we'll finally find out are they cake or are they biscuits
and feby will be the judge that game is it cake Yeah!
Some of those are so crazy, oh my gosh.
One that looks just like a shoe.
Personally, I'm on team cake.
I feel like it's not good enough of the biscuit qualities
for it to be a biscuit.
When you decide it was a cake, because it goes hard when
stale rather than soft.
Oh.
Don't cry.
Ooh, it's like chocolate on it.
Here we go, yeah, it's chocolate and then an orange tangy
center.
Oh.
Mm.
Cool.
And you definitely want some, are you guys finished your
team?
Oh, I don't know.
Oh no, me too, so fine.
But I better the tea.
I will imagine the tea.
Cake.
Mmm.
So good.
The only thing that makes it remotely biscuit-like is just
like the crunch from the chocolate, but that's not the thing
itself.
Yeah.
I think also like the shape of it makes you want to be like,
oh yeah, this is a cookie.
But no, this is a cake.
British daughter.
Did I tell you guys about my British Okonomiaki?
No.
No?
Yeah, so like I had my Christmas dinner and then there's a
thing that you do in the UK on like Boxing Day where you put
all of the Christmas dinner remnants into like a...
like you mash it and you eat it as like a big pancake.
So I did that?
No.
But...
But yes, because I made the pancake and then I put like
Okonomiyaki sauce and mayonnaise on there and made like
British style Okonomiyaki.
Was it peak?
It was so peak.
You could say it was a banger in that.
Yeah, banger in that.
Yeah!
Not a toad in the hole though, right?
That sounds horrible.
Excuse me.
It was lovely.
Yeah, bubble and squeak.
What is a bubble and a squeak?
Is it like a toad in the hole?
I was teaching Phoebe about toad in the hole.
I saw that clip too.
Oh no!
What is a toad in the hole?
So toad in the hole is sausages in like batter.
So it's kind of like a sausage, like, do you ever have a
Yorkshire pudding?
No.
Okay, it was kind of like a big Yorkshire pudding with
sausages in it, would be the way I would describe it.
Like a, like pancake-y batter and then there's lots of
sausages inside.
So is that like also a British Okinawa yashi?
I've not tried toad in the hole with a conomereky sauce, but
I reckon it would go pretty hard actually Really?
I don't know.
I reckon it would now.
Now interestingly Which one am I now going for?
Which one am I now craving?
Honestly, I'm gonna do a cornbread Wow, yes, it is very very
good.
Yes.
I'm gonna have one too.
I want some I need something salty after all this.
Yeah, you know There's a lot of sweet.
I can't grab it.
There we go.
What would we say like the standout winners for both savory
and sweet savory this guy i agree but but where's my guy
where's my dude where's the regular monster bunch bag oh i
think i took it oh it's okay well imagine this but like
normal oh that's that guy monster so close so close yeah
yeah yeah so good it's very delicious and what about the
sweet for me it's gotta be okay but i don't i don't think
necessarily agree it was it was quite good and very unique
experience the mint cake however you know that you enjoyed
the bake well a lot I really liked the bake well but I also
really like this guy too yeah that was really good to be
honest I kind of like don't really feel the American sweet
snacks that much no neither they're nostalgic yeah yeah yeah
yeah they're nostalgic but as a snack I would be like, yeah,
I don't need to buy this again.
Maybe the Bakewells, maybe?
The Bakewells were pretty fantastic.
Well, I would say maybe we're split, but I would say we both
would vote, you know, we all would vote for a British one
for sweet.
So I would say we can say the results.
The winner of the savoury category is Team USA Cornbread
Crisp.
Yeah!
of the sweet category.
I would say maybe it's a toss up between Kendall Mint Cake
and Cherry Bakewell.
We could probably, let's say the Mint Cake because like, by
the majority.
Yeah, I think they could be a joint winner.
And the winner of the sweet section, joint winners, Team
United Kingdom, Kendall Mint Cake and Cherry Bakewells.
Yeah!
Which I guess kind of means it's a draw.
right?
Yeah it is.
Very nice.
Cultural exchange.
Yeah.
I'm gonna bring some snacks from like Ranch 99 or the Asian
supermarket next time too.
Like Chinese snacks and stuff.
Yeah.
I want to try.
Yippee.
Yay.
And I'm glad that it seemed to work fine from my new mini PC
first time streaming from the mini PC.
That's exciting.
Yay!
glad it worked glad it worked confirmed you're gonna be able
to keep doing fun streams while you're traveling it was the
setup that Minto has shared yeah on Twitter before actually
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be purchasing it myself soon too so
we can do we're all working the minstrap it's a good stride
it's a reliable stride yay yeah glad you guys enjoyed it we
got any if you guys checked out the fan club artist for this
month.
Very exciting.
Yeah.
It's so cute.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So cute.
And it's like a flower viewing scene.
Yeah.
For spring.
And those stickers are so cute too.
Yeah.
They've been like hidden, right?
People have to, you guys have to get them in the mail to see
what they're fully like.
They're very scary and cute.
So sweet.
They love to tuna.
Yeah, thank you tuna.
Thank you tuna.
Tuna.
So, what is the thing with tuna fish?
You say tuna fish when you have it and like, when do you say
tuna fish?
I just say tuna.
Oh, wait.
Is this tuna fish alive?
Well, someone gaslight you.
I heard that everyone in America says tuna fish.
I think that's what it says like on the things.
Oh, no.
Hannah?
Oh, okay.
Never mind then.
No, I mean, I'm sure there are people that say tuna fish.
You can't say tuna fish.
But you can say just tuna.
Older people, okay, interesting.
Now, honey, tuna fish.
Oh, yeah.
It sounds like an old person thing.
Tuna fish.
Tuna is the chicken of the sea.
Chicken of the sea.
Yeah, I mean, how much of tuna?
Yeah.
Yeah, tuna.
Yeah, we might need to, you know, have some kind of a savory
meal at some point today after all this.
I need to finish all of these partially opened penguins.
Yeah, sorry, Phoebe.
No, don't be sorry, I love them.
Yeah, that's good.
And I'm still hoarding the very last piece of my arrow
peppermint as well.
Yeah, I finished the fruit bio for it.
Wait, oh no, I have to finish the roast beef monster.
Yeah, you do have to finish those.
There's like a whole cocktail skit too.
Wow.
on over there.
Yeah.
Oh, but it was so much fun.
Thank you guys for joining us for this fun first MVP of
course.
Yeah, guys.
The first of many so please keep an eye out for more in the
future.
Yeah.
Wow.
You're going to be a big.
You're going to be a big one.
Oh, thank you for the sugar.
Oh, it's always nice to see Dennis as the EEC students.
Ex-expresses have you all in one place.
Super fun street.
It's all very educational.
We have learned things to try and maybe some things to
avoid.
Yeah, those monster munch roast beef Yes, thank you Thank
you, thank you everyone This is the ugliest heart.
Oh, just There you go.
Yeah.
Oh, what's this?
This looks very stylish Okay guys, I do have something I
want to ask before we go.
It is a rare opportunity.
Oh, no We need to know.
Oh, we need to we need to know I'm scared Hang on, I'm just
looking for a pen, give me a second.
Oh, go ahead me.
A pen.
Where'd you think?
Oh yeah, I know.
I thought that too, but I was kidding.
I thought that too.
Okay, we have this cinmerole pen.
Okay.
Guys, I need to know, are you also lateral quadrupeds with
me?
Or are you dynamic tripods or lateral tripods?
I need to know.
What does it mean?
Show me the way you hold a pen.
Oh, actually...
Hang on, I need the diagram.
All right, we need to know.
It's, you know, they say that lateral quadrupeds are the
height of emotional intelligence, guys.
Um, okay, Ty, ways, ways hold a pen.
Um, dynamic lateral.
Okay, I'm getting the picture up guys.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna classify.
It's basically like which finger do you put on the pen and
do you then like cross?
Okay, you're, you're across the thumb.
So you are lateral, but, hang on, yeah.
Wait, what, what, what?
Minto, I think you might also be a lateral quadruple.
She's a lateral quadruple.
Am I?
What does that mean?
Oh, Vicky's so overwhelming.
People will tell you that you right, wrong, and you must
tell them that they are wrong.
You must tell them that they are wrong.
All those, listen, all those dynamic tripods, they will try
and tell you that there is a correct way to hold a pen.
You must not listen to them.
I'm again, I'm, yeah, I wanna be against everybody.
I'm against the word!
Yeah!
Okay, now for you, Phoebe.
I'm scared because I've always been told that I hold pencils
wrong and stuff.
But like, maybe not in a classifiable way.
I actually hold it like this.
the flicky's face you're bouncing on this finger right um i
actually it's just kind of kind of sort of just well it's
like supporting my middle finger i guess but like you've got
both but this is the main supporting finger i think i
believe maybe oh well it's more like i could write like this
too but so i don't need this one are you cross i'm trying to
work out if you're crossing this thumb or not, right?
Like, what is your thumb doing?
Let me like actually write on something.
We might, guys, we might all be lateral quadrupeds and I'm
about to cry.
No, God.
Wait, yeah, this is, this kind of, this is the supporting
finger, this one.
Okay.
But I think, I do think your thumb is more on the pen
though.
I think probably you're a dynamic quadruped.
I think you're a dynamic quadruped, but it's okay.
It's okay.
What does that mean?
You're still a quadruped.
You're still a quadrupole.
So you're not you're not you're not a dirty dynamic tripod.
That's right chat
But I'm a dynamic quadruple.
Yeah, yeah, yeah You're a lateral quadruple with me.
We're the we're the like the least in the population oh and
people tell us that we're wrong.
So people, we're the ones that are, we're the, we're the
further evolved.
Yes, the further evolved.
That's right, Chad, that's right.
Evolution is heading towards.
Yes.
Wait, what are all the time?
They have all these like, they have these products online
that are like correcting pens where they get kids to write
with dynamic tripods.
No.
Yeah.
They make the lateral quadrupas correct their way of right
of using a pen no it's it's ridiculous it's actually
ridiculous and i'm very grateful that both of you are
quadrupas i'm glad i'm not a tripod anyway sorry i needed to
know i needed to know um i need i need it to know sorry yes
anyway oh we found out we found out for good anyways
quadrupod.exe Codephone.com.
C.
Anything else?
You guys go coming up?
Any, oh, any announcements from anyone?
Stuff coming up?
I'm streaming.
I have to go party.
Hmm?
I have to go party after this stream.
Oh, okay.
Anyone else have any other announcements?
Oh, I think I didn't even realize that either.
Like, yeah.
Especially with the tea.
Yeah, I saw much tea.
Oh.
One sip makes laugh.
Two sip makes happy and relaxed moments.
Three sips makes potty.
Thank you, everybody.
Quadruplex.exe.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you for joining the first MVP of Colab.
Thank you.
Wait, is it all?
Oh, there it is.
Yupi.
Yupi, yupi, yupi.
Thank you everyone!
Thank you everybody!
Thank you!
Goodbye everyone!
Bye bye!